[Music]
sarah is in milwaukee hey sarah welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we know
um we're a family of three and we
currently rent an apartment
and our situation is that
we originally signed a contract with one
of my husband's friends
and a contract for what
uh oh i'm sorry for a realtor
we're renting looking for a house now oh
and
he's a buyer's agent yes
okay all right and
we thought we were making the right
choice signing this realtor contract
but as we moved along since last october
he just wasn't doing a lot for us we
always had to call
him to open doors um
so we're in this kind of sticky
situation and now we're stuck in this
contract with our realtor
until october but we're looking to move
almost now we're on baby set
four and five now and so we're wondering
um what can we do to get out of our
contract without hurting feelings since
it's a
my husband's friend as well as
hopefully not paying fees to get out of
our contract
i'm not paying a fee he hadn't done his
job
so let's just take that off the table
but sarah are you saying the contract
has
fees and you're asking about it they
signed a buyer's contract saying if they
buy a house that he gets paid
but um he's going to release you from
that contract because he's not done his
job
because you've had him since october
right sarah
yep and it's a one-year contract i know
but that's just bs
okay so your husband just needs to call
his buddy and go
look george sorry man i love you
but you suck as a realtor and so
uh we're still friends but you're you're
gonna send me an email right now
releasing me from this contract i'm done
now he can be nicer than that as i said
he needs to be nicer i know but i mean
that's the bottom line
right if he's your friend he should let
you out because he hadn't done his job
if he doesn't i'm going to his broker
going to his managing broker and we'll
raise kane
okay by then the friendship's gone by
the way
yeah and sarah i think the goal here is
is not to lose the friendship over the
home i mean the the
of the situation so the okay
dave just gave me a face okay no
seriously though i think sitting down
i mean i'm thinking if i'm in his
position and one of my best friends had
something and i signed something with
her she didn't do her job i think i
would sit her and be like hey listen
we had a goal by this for the bet for
the good of my family we're gonna have
to move on to something else
because we have to do this and like and
i wish it worked out but it didn't
and so my goal here is to save the
relationship i don't want to be awkward
so i'm going to just say it out loud
this is what we're dealing
with and hey how can you help me get out
of it yeah and that's it if
you do that and they don't let you out
then you didn't have a friendship to
start with
yeah i mean if you didn't let you out of
it that's weird for sure for sure
i agree with that yes i mean reverse the
reverse the shoes okay
you didn't do your job and your friend
came to you sarah
you would let them out right right
i would too absolutely do you feel like
that conversation will go okay with your
husband and the friend
i would think so yeah i know my
husband's nervous about it
yeah sure i understand i'm nervous
that your husband signed a contract with
this guy in the first place so now your
husband needs to clean this mess up
he needs to sit down with this guy
tomorrow and have a cup of coffee
tomorrow which as a sidebar sarah too
this is a great
point that we always talk about your
home is one of your
if not your largest asset that you have
in your life and so many people do this
they have a friend they have an
aunt they have a dog walker's
grandmother i mean it's just like the
craziness of people that let people sell
their homes which is their largest asset
which is a huge mistake that's one
reason we have elp our endorsement of
local providers for real estate agents
across the country because it's like
you need someone good and i think i mean
we've been in positions where friends
you know want to offer their services
but it's a big deal financially and
we're like
i'm so sorry i'm so thankful you're
willing to we're going to go this other
route though and
and so just be so mindful everyone out
there listening that
when it comes to your home get someone
that is good because again this is a
place that
almost anyone can become a real estate
agent i mean you take a few classes and
all that not to downplay
the industry but it's really easy so a
lot of people get into it that aren't
that good
monkey can get a real estate license
getting a real estate license a monkey
can get a real estate license it doesn't
make you a it doesn't make you a real
estate agent just because you got a
license
and so uh you know yeah you've gotta you
gotta break this out rachel's exactly
right it's too large a thing
so here's the thing sarah um
big deal your family
your home purchase little deal
hubby's friend's feelings are hurt
really
i mean so you need to sit down with him
give him every opportunity to be a man
himself and do the right thing and
release you
but um i'm just not hey let me tell you
rachel we bought the lot that our house
is sitting on
yeah and it had a lot of zeros on it
it's an expensive lot up on a big old
hill
and i bought it through our elp who
brought me the deal
yes and he got paid a nice commission i
got a real estate license
but he got paid a nice commission i
didn't cut him out he brought me the
deal
and some friend of your mothers who'd
had her license three weeks got all
pissed off
well kiss my butt i mean really you get
no you get
you got no standing to be put you you
didn't bring me into that lot deal
you're dead gum right i didn't you've
had your license 36 seconds
and just cause you work out the why
doesn't mean you can with my wife
doesn't mean you can't
you can save the house and the
friendship i believe in you i know well
i'm still friends with that woman but
you know my god she's completely out of
line this friend of theirs
is completely out of line i agree he
hasn't delivered and he hasn't
offered to release them so i mean that's
how this works
this is a rocket science this is the
dave ramsey show